This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This past May, the city of Los Angeles rolled out a brand new state-of-the-art feature for bus shelters. It's called Los Numbrita. Los Numbrita is a metal screen that's intended to provide shade for the thousands of people who ride the bus every day. The shade screen is about 2 feet wide, 10 feet tall, and it kind of looks like a curved,
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今年五月，洛杉矶市为公交候车亭推出了一项全新的、最先进的功能。它叫“小阴凉”。“小阴凉”是一个金属遮阳网，旨在为每天数千名乘公交出行的人提供阴凉。这个遮阳网大约2英尺宽、10英尺高，看起来有点像一个弯曲的、
teal, metal surfboard filled with tiny little holes. Right away, Angelina knows we're not happy. I was wondering why it was here because I was like, well, what's the point? Criticism has been swift online with people comparing this to a cheese grater. Many of the online complaints cited Lawson Brita's size. While the designers say Law Sambrida can provide shade for two or three people, critics say it doesn't look big enough for even a single person. And many people are furious about the cost. The La Sambrida prototype cost around $10,000.
青绿色的、布满小孔的金属冲浪板。安杰利娜很快就知道我们并不高兴。我当时在想它为什么会在这里，因为我想，这有什么意义呢？网上批评声四起，人们将其比作奶酪擦。许多网络投诉提到了“小阴凉”的尺寸。虽然设计者称“小阴凉”可以为两到三个人提供阴凉，但批评者认为它看起来连一个人都容纳不下。许多人对成本感到愤怒。“小阴凉”原型的造价约为1万美元并不完美，但
Clearly, La Sambrida isn't perfect, but in Los Angeles, a little shade goes a long way. The controversy around Los Enbrita got me thinking about a conversation we had in 2020 with the journalist Sam Block. Sam is working on a book about the politics of shade and how shade, coverage, and LA has become one of the city's biggest hot-button issues. Today, we'll get Sam's thoughts about Los Amrita and whether the controversial shade fixture could actually be a good thing for shade starved Angelinos. But first, my conversation with Sam Block from 2020.
显然，“小阴凉”并非十全十美，但在洛杉矶，一点阴凉就能起大作用。“小阴凉”引发的争议让我想起了我们在2020年与记者萨姆·布洛克的对话。萨姆正在写一本关于遮阳政治的书，探讨在洛杉矶，阴凉、遮蔽物如何成为该市最受关注的焦点问题之一。今天，我们将听听萨姆对“小阴凉”的看法，以及这个备受争议的遮阳设施是否真的能给极度缺乏阴凉的洛杉矶人带来好处。但首先，是我在2020年与萨姆·布洛克的对话。
What did you notice about Los Angeles when you started walking around the city? What did I notice? I noticed that there was no one around. I noticed that the people who were around would have to position themselves in such a way to protect themselves from the sunlight. What do you mean? I noticed people waiting for the buses behind telephone poles.
当你开始在洛杉矶四处步行时，你注意到了什么？我注意到了什么？我注意到周围空无一人。我注意到周围仅有的人不得不调整自己的位置，以此来躲避阳光。你是什么意思？我注意到人们在电线杆后面等公交车。
I noticed people waiting behind the people, waiting behind telephone poles because there's only that small sliver of shade that people were protected from the sunlight. Why is shade so important? Los Angeles, like most every city in the world is heating up. There are some scientists who I speak to
我注意到人们在人群后面等待，在电线杆后面等待，因为只有那一小片阴凉能让人免受阳光照射。为什么阴凉如此重要？洛杉矶和世界上大多数城市一样，正在变暖。我采访过一些科学家，
who have found that in hot, dry, arid environments like Los Angeles, but also phoenix, that shade is the most important factor when it comes to human comfort, more than air temperature, more than humidity, more than wind speed. And there's a close relationship between human thermal comfort and mortality and illness and heat stroke.
他们发现，在洛杉矶以及菲尼克斯这样炎热、干旱、干燥的环境中，阴凉是影响人类舒适度的最重要因素，甚至超过了气温、湿度和风速。人类的热舒适度与死亡率、疾病以及中暑之间存在着紧密的关系。
If you don't have shade, if you're not protected from the sun, you can become dizzy, you can become disoriented, you can become confused, authorgic, dehydrated. If you are obese or elderly or pregnant that can tip into more dangerous things like heart attack or organ failure. And so what is the magnitude of the problem in LA? There are a few different ways of thinking about it. We can talk about shade in terms of tree canopy, which is a very serious problem. Los Angeles has terribly unequal tree canopy.
如果你没有阴凉，如果不防晒，你可能会感到头晕、迷失方向、思维混乱、嗜睡、脱水。如果你是肥胖者、老年人或孕妇，这可能会引发更危险的状况，如心脏病发作或器官衰竭。那么在洛杉矶，问题的严重程度有多大？有几种不同的思考方式。我们可以从树冠的角度来谈论阴凉，这是一个非常严重的问题。洛杉矶的树冠分布极不均衡。
And by tree canopy, I just mean coverage. Let's say you're in outer space looking down on LA. You'll see parts of the city that are covered in green. And you'll see parts of the city that are not. They're baking an asphalt. And those two aty follow lines of wealth. It's a problem with tree canopy. It's a problem in terms of the built urban form.
说到树冠，我指的就是覆盖率。假设你在太空中俯瞰洛杉矶。你会看到城市里绿树成荫的地区，也会看到没有绿树的地区。它们在柏林油路（应为沥青，但此处按原文保持口语化，译为：它们在沥青路面上烘烤。）而这两者遵循着财富的分界线。这是一个树冠的问题。这也是城市建成形态的问题。
Los Angeles is notoriously anti-density. Los Angeles has this image of itself as not being New York City, in fact being the anti-New York City. So sunlight and open space is a part of the culture. That's not necessarily a problem, but it becomes a problem when you can't escape it. So there are no tall buildings to provide, some measure of shade. I wouldn't go as far as to say there are no tall buildings. However, there are a few tall buildings. And there's space pretty far apart. Correct.
众所周知，洛杉矶是反密度的。洛杉矶给自己的形象不是纽约市，实际上它是反纽约市的。因此阳光和开放空间是其文化的一部分。这本身不一定是问题，但当你无法逃避它时，问题就来了。所以没有高楼大厦来提供一定程度的遮阳。我不会走得太远去说那里没有高楼大厦。然而，高楼大厦确实很少。而且它们彼此相距相当远。没错。
They're located in certain height districts downtown being one of them. And even some areas that city planners have designated to be taller neighborhoods, even today they're still fought and contested by neighborhood activists. So I've seen all pictures and I get a sense that Los Angeles used to be greener. Like there was a lot of shade So tell me how the city was designed and how it Developed into this. So time was Los Angeles was a prairie if you look at photos of LA from 150 years ago It's all grasslands and when it was settled by the Spanish downtown
它们位于市中心特定的高度分区内，市中心就是其中之一。即使在城市规划者划定为更高街区的某些地区，直到今天，它们仍然受到社区积极分子的反对和争论。所以我看过以前的照片，我有一种感觉，洛杉矶过去更绿。就像有很多阴凉一样，所以告诉我这座城市是如何设计的，又是如何发展成这样的。曾几何时，洛杉矶是一个草原，如果你看150年前洛杉矶的照片，全是草地，当西班牙人定居时，市中心
Which was the original settlement was laid out according to law of the Indies. The city would roughly conform to a 45 degree angle, so you could have sunlight in the winter and shade and shadow in the summer. So explain the law of the Indies, what does this mean? The law of the Indies means build your cities at 45 degrees, basically. Really? Completely unlike the way we think of most American cities, which have this sort of north-south, east-west, very rich grid. So you have these original settlements that are laid out in such a way as to be able
作为最初的定居点，是按照《印度法》规划的。这座城市大致呈45度角，这样你就可以在冬天晒到太阳，在夏天享受到阴凉。那么请解释一下《印度法》，这是什么意思？《印度法》基本上意味着将你的城市建造成45度角。真的吗？这与我们对大多数美国城市的看法完全不同，那些城市有着这种南北、东西走向的、非常丰富的网格。所以你有这些最初的定居点，它们的设计方式就是为了能够在
to create shadow when you need it and also to bestow sunlight, also when you need it. Spanish architecture tends to have a very strong sense of natural comfort. So you'll see a lot of these kinds of missions and adobeies that have these internal court yards that are shaded. You'll have covered walkways, paseos, and even today you'll see a lot of this and Spanish revival architecture or outdoor malls that have goofy Spanish-ish names. Los Angeles was also in a way sort of a dusty,
需要时制造阴影，同时也能在需要时赐予阳光。西班牙建筑往往有着非常强烈的自然舒适感。所以你会看到很多这样的传道所和土坯房，它们有阴凉的内部庭院。你会看到带顶棚的人行道、步行街，甚至在今天，你还会看到很多这样的西班牙复古建筑或带有滑稽的西班牙风格名字的户外购物中心。在某种程度上，洛杉矶也曾是一个尘土飞扬的、
old west town. So you think about these covered boardwalks, you think about large canvas awnings that are cooling people who are living outside and also cooling indoors, which at the time didn't have air conditioning. And another way that Los Angeles tried to stay cool was through rich, beautiful, kind of flamboyant,
旧西部小镇。所以你想想这些带遮阳棚的木板路，想想那些为生活在户外的人们以及室内降温的大帆布遮阳篷，当时室内还没有空调。洛杉矶试图保持凉爽的另一种方式是通过丰富、美丽、某种程度上浮夸的、
not just tree canopy, but a syncretic, overwhelming variety of exotic, florent phantom. So during this period, there was a recognition of the environment and how to be comfortable inside of it. And when did that go wrong? Funny that you put it that way. Things started to go wrong after cheap electricity came down to Los Angeles with the completion of what's now called the Hoover Dam.
不仅仅是树冠，还有一种融合的、压倒性的异国植物品种。所以在这一时期，人们对环境以及如何在其中感到舒适有了认知。那是什么时候开始出错的呢？真巧，你这么问。随着现在被称为胡佛大坝的工程竣工，廉价电力来到洛杉矶后，事情开始出错了。
So you start to see the city rebuild itself and the new development becomes like we see today. You have controlled air conditioning, you have the automobile, which comes to dominate the city in the 30s and the 40s. And with the automobile, you just have a whole new way of seeing the city. The names of the streets are household words
所以你开始看到这座城市自我重建，新的发展变得和我们今天看到的一样。你有中央空调，有汽车，汽车在30和40年代开始统治这座城市。有了汽车，你就有了一种全新的看待城市的方式。街道的名字家喻户晓，
translated into magic. Fabila stacks of freeways, tremendous turnwights. The city started to think about how to market itself and how to make itself see more attractive to outsiders And this is where you get palm trees Palm trees one essay is said were about as useful for shade as a telephone pole She hated them, but the city was enamored of them and interestingly you have different philanthropists and celebrities starting to think about And interestingly, you have different philanthropists and celebrities starting to think about trees as being a public good, but the palm tree in particular being one that doesn't just message L.A. as a kind of semi-tropical paradise, but also as Mary Pickford said, it's very good
被翻译成魔幻。层叠的高速公路，巨大的转弯。这座城市开始思考如何自我营销，如何让自己对局外人更具吸引力，这就是你得到棕榈树的地方。正如一篇随笔所说，棕榈树对遮阳的作用和电线杆差不多。她讨厌它们，但这座城市却迷恋它们。有趣的是，不同的慈善家和名流开始认为，有趣的是，不同的慈善家和名流开始认为树木是一种公共福利，但棕榈树尤其不仅向外界传达了洛杉矶是一个半热带天堂的信息，而且正如玛丽·皮克福德所说，它非常适合
for window shopping from the CD or car, because the tree trunks aren't that robust. So if you're driving down Symbolovard, you can see all the great stuff, because the palm tree is so narrow. So Los Angeles was also re-zoned in the 1930s to become a single family city. Los Angeles in order to sort of not pacify, not suck up, but to sort of remake itself from the image of the FHA decided that all new single family
从轿车或车里看橱窗，因为树干没那么粗。所以如果你沿着标志性的林荫大道开车，你可以看到所有棒极了的东西，因为棕榈树太窄了。因此，洛杉矶在20世纪30年代也被重新分区，成为一个单户住宅城市。为了不绥靖，不巴结，而是根据联邦住房管理局（FHA）的形象重塑自己，洛杉矶决定所有新建的单户
homes had to come with a front and a side yard. So you start to create a lot of space around them. Los Angeles really starts to hate the idea of density. And so when you have this type of sprawling, not very density, how is the shade distributed? Unevenly. Shade is distributed to people who can afford it. If you go into these neighborhoods that were laid out to be wealthy residential enclaves, you have very wide sidewalks, and the strip of grass where you can tree plant, which is called the parkway, becomes four or five, maybe even ten feet wide. And when you have these wider parkways, you have a greater space to plant a bigger, thicker, leafier tree.
住宅都必须带有前院和侧院。所以你开始在它们周围创造出很多空间。洛杉矶真的开始讨厌密度的概念。所以当你拥有这种蔓延的、密度不高的形态时，阴凉是如何分配的？不均等。阴凉分配给了那些买得起的人。如果你走进那些被规划为富人住宅区的街区，你会发现非常宽的人行道，可以种树的草地带（被称为公园带）变得有四五英尺宽，甚至可能有十英尺宽。当你拥有这些更宽的公园带时，你就有更大的空间来种植更大、更厚、叶子更多的树。
Okay, so the parkway is the area between the sidewalk and the road. Correct. And there's going to be pretty wide, and therefore, have trees with them. Correct. In other neighborhoods that have been redlined, that were designed as sort of worker housing, that were meant to sort of jam people in together, you don't have these kinds of wide residential sidewalks instead of what you have are very narrow sidewalks because these neighborhoods are designed to facilitate automobile passage. So if you have a narrow sidewalk, you don't really have the space to plan to thickly retrieve. Furthermore, it's been incumbent upon property
好吧，公园带就是人行道和道路之间的区域。没错。而且它会相当宽，因此上面会有树木。没错。在其他被划为红线（歧视性住房政策）的街区，这些街区被设计为工人住房，旨在将人们挤在一起，你不会有这种宽阔的住宅人行道，相反，你拥有的是非常狭窄的人行道，因为这些街区的设计是为了方便汽车通行。所以如果你有人行道很窄，你就没有真正的空间来种植茂密的树木。此外，一直以来都是物业
owners and renters to maintain this sort of semi-public space of the parkway. You would think that in a city, whatever is on the sidewalk, whatever is outside of the property line would be managed by the city. That has not historically been the case in Los Angeles. It's been incumbent upon property owners to water trees to maturity and to maintain them. If there's a tree there, it's because someone has taken it upon themselves to water it to maturity and to care for it.
业主和租户有责任维护公园带这种半公共空间。你可能会认为，在一个城市里，无论人行道上有什么，无论在产权线之外有什么，都应该由城市来管理。洛杉矶历史上并非如此。业主有责任将树木浇水至成熟并对其进行维护。如果那里有一棵树，那是因为有人自己掏钱将其浇水至成熟并照顾它。
So each part of that process, the design of where the sidewalk is relative to the street, the fact that a person of wealth could plant and maintain a tree, all these things cause more uneven distribution of shade trees. That's right. And I would also add that in some neighborhoods, I'm thinking about a neighborhood called Hancock Park, which is a flat neighborhood landlocked in the center of the city. There is nothing about it that naturally lends itself over to being a lush, verdant, tree-fistuned paradise.
所以这个过程的每一个部分，人行道相对于街道的位置设计，有钱人可以种植和维护一棵树的事实，所有这些事情都导致了遮阴树木的分配更加不均。没错。我还要补充一点，在某些街区，我想到了一个叫做汉考克公园的街区，这是一个被城市中心陆地包围的平坦街区。它没有任何自然条件能让自己变成一个郁郁葱葱、绿树成荫的天堂。
But the neighborhood was developed as an exclusive wealthy residential enclave. And when that happened, the power lines were undergrounded. There is nothing in the way it is designed specifically to allow for tree growth. This is not the case in most of Los Angeles. So because of this lack of shade trees, there have been efforts to build in shade, especially around bus shelters, but it's been incredibly hard, according to your reporting. So like in your article, you talk about one bus shelter at Glastonal Park. Could you tell me about that and why it was so hard to put shade there?
但这个街区被开发为一个专属的富人住宅区。当这种情况发生时，电力线被埋入地下。它在设计上没有任何专门为了允许树木生长而做出的考虑。洛杉矶大部分地区并非如此。正是因为缺乏遮阴树，人们一直在努力建造遮阴设施，特别是在公交候车亭周围，但根据你的报道，这异常困难。就像在你的文章中，你谈到了格拉瑟尔公园的一个公交候车亭。你能告诉我那里的情况以及为什么在那里设置阴凉如此困难吗？
It was hard because shade is a tripwire. In the instance of the Glacill Park Transit Island, you had a concern neighborhood resident and a neighborhood activist, maybe you'll call them a homeowner, who wanted to throw just a simple bus shelter over a space where she saw people naturally congregating. She ended up talking to an architect who said, let's not do a regular bus shelter. Let's throw some big shade sales in here. When that happens, you have to start thinking about how are we going to fix these shade sales to the ground. And when that happens, you have to start thinking
这很难，因为遮阳是一个触发点。在格拉瑟尔公园公交岛的例子中，有一位关切的社区居民和社区积极分子（也许你会称他们为房主），她想在一个她看到人们自然聚集的地方搭建一个简单的公交候车亭。她最后跟一个建筑师谈了谈，建筑师说，咱们别建常规的公交候车亭了。咱们在这里弄一些大的遮阳帆吧。当这种情况发生时，你就必须开始考虑我们如何将这些遮阳帆固定在地面上。当这种情况发生时，你必须开始考虑
about what's underneath the ground. And you have water mains, you have underground utilities in order to upgrade a sidewalk or a transit island. You then have to start honoring newer regulations like the Americans with disabilities act, so then you have to start making curb cuts to make it wheelchair accessible. So you have to take care of all these other things before you can decide to do this very lightweight sort of low res fix. Right. The sort of the enemies of shade are not always bad guys in this case. ADA compliance is not a bad guy. No. Yeah, like curb cuts, not a bad guy. In this case, ADA compliance is not a bad guy.
地面下有什么。这里有水管，有地下公用设施，为了升级人行道或公交岛，你必须开始遵守更新的法规，比如《美国残疾人法案》（ADA），所以你必须开始削减路缘，使其适合轮椅通行。所以你必须处理好所有这些其他事情，然后才能决定做这种非常轻量级的、低分辨率的修复。没错。这种情况下，遮阳的敌人并不总是坏人。ADA合规性不是坏人。不。是的，比如路缘削减，不是坏人。在这种情况下，ADA合规性不是坏人。
No. Yeah, like, curbats, not a bad guy. Like, all these things are not bad. You know, it's not just sort of around sidewalks. LA doesn't have a lot of shaden at city parks either. So why is that? Why was this never considered valuable? It wouldn't go as so far as to say,
不。是的，比如路缘削减，不是坏人。所有这些事情都不是坏事。你知道，这不仅仅是人行道周围的问题。洛杉矶的城市公园里也没有很多阴凉。这是为什么呢？为什么这从来没有被认为是有价值的？我不会走得太远去说，
it was never considered valuable. Because I'm thinking about a park downtown called Purshing Square that up until the 1950s was a tropical paradise. It was incredibly shady. It was meant for people to kind of hang out and shoot the breeze. And after a while the business elite in the neighborhood decided, first of all, to install underground parking, which gets rid of the whole root system. So you can no longer plant thicker, denser tree canopy.
它从来没有被认为是有价值的。因为我想到了市中心一个叫做潘兴广场的公园，直到20世纪50年代，它还是一个热带天堂。那里阴凉极了。它是为了让人闲逛和聊天而设计的。过了一段时间，该街区的商业精英们决定，首先要安装地下停车场，这破坏了整个根系。所以你再也不能种植更厚、更密集的树冠了。
And part of the reason why Pershing Square was redeveloped in Shornhub its tree canopy is because Los Angeles is a city where residents are worried about crime, a city where residents are worried about homelessness. As I was working on this story, I came across multiple instances where LAPD had installed pull cameras in parks or in public housing projects. And I've been told about something called crime prevention through environmental design, which is this idea that we need to have increased visibility in public spaces. And you can go on Google Street View and go back five, six,
潘兴广场被重新开发并削减树冠的部分原因是因为洛杉矶是一个居民担心犯罪、居民担心无家可归者的城市。在我写这个报道的过程中，我遇到了多起洛杉矶警察局在公园或公共住房项目中安装杆式摄像头的案例。我听说了所谓的“通过环境设计预防犯罪”的概念，这个想法即我们需要提高公共场所的能见度。你可以在谷歌街景上查看五、六年、
seven years. And you can see over time, when a pole camera goes up, a mature street tree goes down. So there's just all these selective pressures where other things are just more important. You know, like it, whether it's, I would call it somewhat the illusion of crime prevention. Correct. No one told me that it actually prevents crime. You know, like it, whether it's, I would call it somewhat the illusion of crime prevention.
七年前的历史影像。随着时间的推移，你会发现当杆式摄像头竖起来时，成熟的行道树就被砍掉了。所以所有这些选择性压力都在发挥作用，让其他事情变得更加重要。你知道，不管是，我称之为某种虚幻的犯罪预防。没错。没有人告诉我它实际上能阻止犯罪。你知道，不管是，我称之为某种虚幻的犯罪预防。
Correct. No one told me that it actually prevents crime. What this detective told me was that it helps the police catch and prosecute criminals, not that it stops them. And then this preference for this underground parking, which makes shallow ground, which therefore you can only have trees that have ball root systems like palm trees. Correct. It just seems like everything is working against it, especially in this city. And so how do you think about how to balance these different factors and their value in an urban setting? Great question. There are a few ways to think about this. I mentioned that in Los Angeles,
没错。没有人告诉我它实际上能阻止犯罪。这位侦探告诉我的是，它帮助警察抓获和起诉罪犯，而不是阻止他们。然后是对这种地下停车场的偏爱，这导致地面变浅，因此你只能种植像棕榈树那样具有球状根系的树木。没错。感觉好像一切都在与之对抗，特别是在这座城市。那么你如何看待如何在城市环境中平衡这些不同的因素及其价值呢？问得好。有几种方法可以思考这个问题。我提到在洛杉矶，
it's homeowners and residents who are responsible for the maintenance and cultivation of street trees. Why does it have to be that way? Why doesn't the city decide that a public urban forest? Why isn't that a value? You might also think about the question of density. I spoke to an architect and what he told me is that maximizing floor space is the name of the game, which means if you only have so much space to work with, which developer is going to say, let's actually carve out some of our floor space to make an arcade or a portico. That's a tough sell. Right. So why doesn't the city properly incentivize developers to create these sort of semi-public shaded
是房主和居民负责行道树的维护和培育。为什么非得这样呢？为什么这座城市不决定建立一个公共城市森林？为什么这不是一种价值？你可能还会考虑密度的问起。我和一位建筑师谈过，他告诉我，最大化楼面面积是关键所在，这意味着如果你只有这么大的空间可以利用，哪个开发商会说，让我们腾出一些楼面空间来做一个拱廊或门廊。这很难推销。没错。那为什么城市不适当地激励开发商在产权线后面创建这种半公共的遮阴
environments behind the property line that are continuous with the sidewalk? And what about just plainland trees? I mean what is LA doing about just adding to the canopy in general? The city is trying to plant more trees. The city has a goal of planting 90,000 trees in the next few years. I am not sufficiently convinced that the city recognizes the infrastructural challenge to planting 90,000 trees. Because as we've been talking about the space in which you can plant a tree is limited. When you have things like an aeroside walk, or overhead power lines, or even regulations that limit or prohibit the planting of a street tree within 45 feet of a driveway, which, let's be real, that's practically all of Los Angeles.
环境，并与人行道连成一片呢？那单纯的种树呢？我的意思是，洛杉矶在总体上增加树冠方面在做些什么？这座城市正在努力种植更多的树木。该市的目标是在未来几年内种植90,000棵树。我并没有充分相信该市认识到了种植90,000棵树所面临的基础设施挑战。正如我们一直在讨论的那样，你可以种树的空间是有限的。当你遇到诸如人行道狭窄、架空电线，甚至是限制或禁止在车道45英尺范围内种植行道树的法规时，说实话，这几乎涵盖了洛杉矶的所有地方。
That makes me think that the city is not understanding the complete wholesale reimagining of the street that's needed in order to plant 90,000 trees. So we've talked a lot about informal urbanism in the show, in sort of interventions. People could install umbrellas and canopies without permission to fix this kind of problem, just in their own neighborhood. Did you find evidence of people doing this and what is the reaction when this happened? People do it all the time. Particularly, I will add, in Latino neighborhoods. There's an urbanist named James Rohas,
这让我觉得这座城市并不理解种植90,000棵树所需的对街道的彻底重构。我们在节目中讨论了很多关于城市非正式主义以及各种干预措施的问题。人们可以在没有许可的情况下安装伞和遮阳篷，以此来解决这种问题，就在他们自己的社区里。你发现有人这样做的证据了吗？当这种情况发生时，反应是什么？人们一直在这样做。我要补充的是，特别是在拉丁裔社区。有一个名叫詹姆士·罗哈斯的城市规划师，
who writes about Latino urbanism, and he has a pretty compelling theory that Latino residents of Los Angeles know how to use the shade, and he leads these wonderful walking tours world. He'll point out shade sales that have been connected between two garages and an alleyway for kids to play in,
他撰写关于拉丁裔城市主义的文章，他有一个非常令人信服的理论，即洛杉矶的拉丁裔居民知道如何利用阴凉，他带领人们进行精彩的步行游览。他会指出连接在小巷中两个车库之间的遮阳帆，供孩子们玩耍，
because it's more comfortable under the shade. He'll point out these elaborate front yards where you have blue polytops, been connected between two garages and an alleyway for kids to play in because it's more comfortable under the shade. Or he'll point out these elaborate front yards where you have blue polytarp, just strong across a space, or maybe exotic trees that are sort of overflowing into the street. Well, that sounds great to me, but I get the impression that the city doesn't always see things the same way. What I did find is that in the private realm, those things are tolerated. When they step into the public and when they step onto the sidewalk, things become more
因为在树荫下更舒服。他会指出那些精致的前院，那里有蓝色的塑料布跨越空间，或者有些异物植物溢出到街道上。听起来很棒，但我给人的印象是，城市并不总是以同样的方式看待事物。我发现的是，在私有领域，这些事情是可以被容忍的。当它们走进公共场所，踏上人行道时，事情就变得更加
complicated. I write about a grassroots shade shelter on Figueroa and Avenue 26 in the Cyprus Park neighborhood near the LA River. And a barber named Tony Cornelho would not admit that it was he who made this really great fantastic shade shelter made out of like an Ibeam and a great tarp and a couple bus benches, but he told me that he recognized the need for people when they're waiting for the bus just to have some protection. Tony or someone had to take down this grassroots bus shelter because it was an obstruction in the public right of way. this grassroots bus shelter because it was an obstruction in the public right of way. The city processes 16,000 obstructions in the public right of way every year. If property owners,
复杂了。我写过一个关于菲格罗亚街和赛普拉斯公园社区26大街交界处（靠近洛杉矶河）的一个草根遮阳棚的故事。一个名叫托尼·科尔内霍的理发师不承认是他制作了这个非常棒的遮阳棚，它是用工字梁、优质防水布和几个公交长椅做成的，但他告诉我，他认识到人们在等公交车时需要一些保护。托尼或其他什么人不得不拆除这个草根公交候车亭，因为它是公共通行权上的路障。这座草根公交候车亭，因为它是公共通行权上的路障。每年处理16,000起公共通行权上的路障。如果房主、
if residents did not fear that the city would come after them, threatening them with fines, perhaps we would see more grassroots urbanism. I think it's pretty surprising to think of shade as a political inequity issue. I think it surprises a lot to think of shade as a political inequity issue. I think it surprises a lot of people. Tell me about your awakening of this and convincing people of it and just make your best case for what it is that you want people to think about when they think about shade in the city. Shade in a city is, to me, respect for people who can't afford to duck into an air-conditioned cafe or a lift when it gets too hot. Shade is to me an understanding that the world is changing and we want to protect citizens, the most vulnerable citizens, who can't
如果居民不担心城市会找上门来，用罚款威胁他们，也许我们会看到更多的草根城市主义。我认为把遮阳当作一个政治不平等问题来看待是很令人惊讶的。我认为很多人都会对此感到惊讶。跟我讲讲你是如何意识到这一点的，又是如何说服别人的，请尽你最大努力阐述当人们思考城市阴凉时，你希望他们思考的是什么。在我看来，城市里的阴凉是对那些在天气太热时去不起带空调的咖啡馆或叫不起车的人的尊重。在我看来，阴凉是一种理解，即世界正在改变，我们要保护那些无法保护自己的公民，即最脆弱的公民。
protect themselves. And it's also just nicer to be in the shade, it's cooler in the shade. I always walk on the shady side of the street. It's easier to see in the shade. I spoke to a scientist who said that direct sunlight is the kind of light that you have when you perform oral surgery.
而且在阴凉处呆着也更好，阴凉处更凉爽。我总是走在街道阴凉的一侧。在阴凉处更容易看清东西。我采访过一位科学家，他说直射阳光就像你进行口腔手术时所面对的那种光线。
That's not pleasant. No, dappled light is more like reading a book. Yeah. So I want my city to help me read a book. I don't want to perform a moral surgery. Thanks for coming in. I appreciate it. Yeah, thanks for having me, Roman.
那可不舒服。不，斑驳的光影更像是读一本书。是的。所以我希望我的城市帮我读一本书。我不想做口腔手术。谢谢你来。我很感激。是的，谢谢你邀请我，罗曼。
When we come back, Sandblock talks about Lawson Brita and the future of Sh shade in Los Angeles. [♪ Music playing in background, in seems like a perfect solution to the problems Sam Locke mentioned in our interview. It's easy to install, and the city believes it could help thousands of people stay cool. The city says the shades structure is designed to help with gender equity, since most of L.A.'s transit riders are women. But for the most part, Angelino's aren't thrilled with La Sambrida, largely because of the underwhelming design. La Sambrida is a metal grate that shaped like a surfboard
我们回来后，萨姆·布洛克将谈论“小阴凉”以及洛杉矶遮阳的未来。（背景音乐播放中）这似乎是解决萨姆·布洛克在采访中提到的问题的一个完美方案。它易于安装，该市认为这可以帮助数千人保持凉爽。该市表示，遮阳设施旨在帮助实现性别平等，因为洛杉矶的大多数公交乘客都是女性。但总的来说，洛杉矶人对“小阴凉”并不兴奋，主要是因为其设计不尽如人意。“小阴凉”是一个金属网格，形状像一个冲浪板，
and pock marks with tiny holes. Could it say it's too thin to provide any meaningful shade at all? After a social media backlash, La Sambrida became a national news story earlier this summer, and not for good reasons. A plan to provide more sun protection and safety for LA bus riders seems like a no-brainer right, but the new shades have left some shaking their heads. A Sam, welcome back and tell me, why are people so angry about La Sabrita? The frustrations with La Sabrita are, they emerge from a few causes, let's say. Los Angeles public officials have been telling bus riders and constituents and other Angelenos
上面布满了小孔。有人说它太薄了，根本无法提供任何有意义的阴凉？在社交媒体引发强烈反对后，“小阴凉”今年夏天早些时候成为了全国新闻故事，而且不是因为好的原因。为洛杉矶公交乘客提供更多防晒和安全的计划似乎是一个不费脑子的决定，对吧，但新的遮阳设施却让一些人直摇头。萨姆，欢迎回来，告诉我，为什么人们对“小阴凉”如此愤怒？对“小阴凉”的不满，可以说源于几个原因。洛杉矶的公共官员一直在告诉公交乘客、选民和其他洛杉矶人，
for years that they want to create more shade. One example of this is with bus shelters. There are, I think, around well over 600,000 boardings on buses every day in Los Angeles. And only about a quarter of those bus stops have any kind of shelter from the sun. And as temperatures rise and heatwaves become more common. And as I would say rhetoric ramps up about the importance of taking public transit instead of driving for ecological and emissions related purposes. Many angelinos are finding that the street conditions just aren't conducive. They're not comfortable.
多年来，他们一直想创造更多的阴凉。其中一个例子就是公交候车亭。我认为，洛杉矶每天有远超60万次的公交乘车。而其中只有大约四分之一的公交车站有任何形式的防晒遮蔽物。随着气温上升和热浪变得越来越普遍。正如我所说，关于出于生态和排放目的乘坐公共交通而不是开车的宣传力度也在加大。许多洛杉矶人发现，街道条件根本不具备这种环境。它们很不舒适。
They don't entice people. People would so much rather be in the comfort of their own car instead of taking the bus because they're made to wait in the elements. So, Lawson Brita, when it arrived, was also couched in the rhetoric of gender equity. Now, I want to back up for a second on this because this is an important point. The Los Angeles Department of Transportation, one of the many agencies that controls, well, transportation, but also just various ways of getting around the city and various, let's just say, right of way jurisdictions has for a few years now been working with a design group to try to figure out how to better serve
它们无法吸引人。人们宁愿享受自己汽车的舒适，也不愿坐公交车，因为他们被迫在恶劣的天气中等待。因此，“小阴凉”问世时，也夹杂着性别平等的说辞。现在，我想稍微倒退一下，因为这是一个重要的点。洛杉矶交通局（控制交通以及在城市中出行的各种方式和各种路权管辖权的众多机构之一）几年来一直在与一个设计小组合作，试图弄清楚如何更好地服务
its female bus riders. Ridership on buses and L.A. excuse female, women the way they ride the bus tends to be different from men, you know. The system is set up essentially to make sure that commuters can get to work from 9 to 5. But there are a lot of people in L.A. who maybe take the bus in the middle of the day. Maybe they're chaining more trips together because they are trying to run more errands, let's say, or they're picking up their kids from school. It's not really designed for them.
其女性公交乘客。洛杉矶公交车的乘客以女性居多，女性乘车的方式往往与男性不同，你知道的。该系统的设置本质上是为了确保通勤者能够从9点到5点上班。但洛杉矶有很多在中午乘公交车的人。也许他们因为要跑更多的差事而串联了更多的行程，或者他们去接孩子放学。它并不是真正为他们设计的。
So gender equity is an attempt to address those problems. The reason that Lawson Brita caused this uproar, this Twitter revolt, is because the high-minded language of gender equity, the magnitude of the problem, let's say, of gender equity, not matched by this minuscule 24-inch screen bolted on the side of the road to this bus pole bike, to say that you're solving gender equity with this, is a little bit insulting. So, what are some of the good things about Lawson Breed? There must be some good things. Lawson Breedum makes shade, and any shade is better than none at all. I like to talk to a heat scientist at Arizona State University, her name is Arianna Medell.
因此，性别平等是解决这些问题的一种尝试。“小阴凉”之所以引起这种轩然大波，这场推特反抗，是因为性别平等的高尚语言、性别平等问题的严重程度，与这个微不足道的、固定在路边公交杆上的24英寸屏幕不相称，用这个来声称你正在解决性别平等问题，有点侮辱人。那么，“小阴凉”有什么好处呢？肯定有一些好处。“小阴凉”能提供阴凉，任何阴凉都比没有好。我喜欢采访亚利桑那州立大学的一位热学科学家，她的名字叫阿里安娜·梅德尔。
She uses this heat index called the mean radiant temperature, which is basically, how much heat is crashing into your body from the sun, from the air, from all the reflected surfaces. And I called her after this thing blew up and I asked her about it. And she said, you know, what is wrong with all you people? Why are you all dumping on this? You know, what this does is it blocks direct solar radiation from hitting you. And direct solar radiation is the number one input in mean radiant temperature. So it helps.
她使用一种叫做平均辐射温度的热指数，这基本上是：阳光、空气和所有反射表面撞击你身体的热量有多少。在这件事爆发后我打电话给她，向她询问了这件事。她说，你知道，你们这些人怎么了？你们为什么都要抨击这个？你知道，这做的是阻挡直接的太阳辐射击中你。而直接太阳辐射是平均辐射温度中最重要的输入。所以它有帮助。
It does create some cooling. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, we talked about this a few years ago. It's like people will line up behind a pole just to get a little bit of relief and a pole, you know, like something that's too intraswide. Someone describe that to me as the game we all play when you ride the bus in Los Angeles.
它确实能带来一些降温。对。是的。我的意思是，我们几年前讨论过这个问题。就像人们会排在电线杆后面只为了获得一点点阴凉一样，而电线杆，你知道的，比两英寸还窄。有人向我将其描述为我们在洛杉矶坐公交车时玩的游戏。
You queue up behind telephone poles or utility poles, you queue up behind someone else. I don't think it's very dignified having to sort of hide from the sun in these accidental shady spaces on the street, but people do it because it works, because you're getting the sun off your skin and there are a number of psychological
你排在电线杆或公用电线杆后面，你排在其他人后面。我认为在街上这些偶然的阴凉处躲避阳光并不是一件很有尊严的事，但人们这样做是因为它管用，因为你可以让阳光离开你的皮肤，当你这样做时，会发生许多心理
and physiological things that happen when you do that. Okay, so we're getting into the crux of this because this is exactly why I thought of you when I saw this thing. And to me, the shape of this thing is exactly the negative space created by the various regulations and bureaucracies of everything else surrounding it. There are many things stopping shade structures from being built. And some of those things are not necessarily bad things
和生理上的事情。好吧，我们要切入正题了，因为这正是我看到这个东西时想起你的原因。在我看来，这个东西的形状正是由周围其他所有法规和官僚机构所产生的负空间。有许多因素阻止了遮阳设施的建造。其中一些因素本身不一定是不好的事情
in and of themselves. They're ADA compliance. There's a reason why a shade structure has holes because it's, you know, it needs to not collect garbage on it and water and things like that. So could you describe Lawson Breta in terms of the design constraints as you understand them. Sure.
它们是ADA（美国残疾人法案）合规性。遮阳结构有孔是有原因的，因为你需要它不收集垃圾和水之类东西。所以你能按照你理解的设计限制来描述一下“小阴凉”吗？当然。
Let's talk about the shape of La Sambrita, this skateboard popsicle, kind of oval shape. It couldn't be fatter, let's say. It couldn't be truly circular, like a parasol or octagonal like a stop sign because if it was too wide, this structure, which is again bolted to a bus pole, would blow over in the wind. So it had to be aerodynamic, let's say, for this specific purpose. It had to be perforated also for wind permeability,
让我们来谈谈“小阴凉”的形状，这个滑板冰棒一样的椭圆形。比这更胖是不可能的。它不可能是真正的圆形（像阳伞一样）或八边形（像停止标志），因为如果它太宽，这个再次被固定在公交杆上的结构会被风吹倒。所以为了这个特定的目的，它必须是符合空气动力学的。它也必须是有穿孔的以便透风，
right, so you don't want like a sail for the whole thing to just sort of get picked up and blown away. But the reason this screen is bolted to a bus pole instead of a fix to the ground where people are in the first place has to do with the tough knot of regulations around how the public right of way is used and allocated and controlled in Los Angeles, and almost none of it has to do with making shade.
对吧，所以你不会希望整个东西就像一张帆一样被风吹走。但这个遮阳网被固定在公交杆上，而不是固定在人们所在的地面上，这与洛杉矶如何使用、分配和控制公共通行权的繁重复杂的法规有关，几乎没有一条与制造阴凉有关。
ADA clearance is important. We want accessible sidewalks. For that reason, a narrow sidewalk, which UCLA researchers have found tend to be more common in POC neighborhoods in LA than white neighborhoods. Narrow sidewalks that were designed before modern ideas of accessibility are pretty much gobbled up by this need for ADA clearance, which again is a good thing. The solution to me seems to be, well, if you need more space, you can expand the sidewalk. You can work with the transit agencies to build into the road, to take some space away from cars and give it to pedestrians and bus riders, which, again, city leadership in Los Angeles says they want to encourage that kind of behavior.
ADA净空高度很重要。我们需要无障碍人行道。出于这个原因，加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）的研究人员发现，窄人行道在洛杉矶的有色人种社区比白人社区更常见。在现代无障碍理念出现之前设计的窄人行道几乎被这种对ADA净空的需求给吞噬了，这再次说明这是一件好事。在我看来，解决方案似乎是，如果你需要更多空间，你可以扩宽人行道。你可以与交通机构合作，向道路延伸，从汽车那里分流一些空间给行人和公交乘客，再次说明，洛杉矶的城市领导层表示他们希望鼓励这种行为。
Or the other thing you can do, which some transit agencies have done in San Antonio, is to get an easement on private property, and to take some of the private property that's next the sidewalk and give it to the public. The other reason why this shade structure is so spatially constrained is because there is this tendency amongst the many agencies in Los Angeles that control the public right of way, excuse me, not to work well together. And if you speak to people in the streets department, or somewhere else in public works, they all have their good reasons for wanting to work within their own agencies. They have not been properly directed to collaborate and coordinate on projects that holistically serve their constituents,
或者你可以做的另一件事，圣安东尼奥的一些交通机构已经做过的，是在私有财产上获得地役权，拿走人行道旁边的一些私有财产并将其交给公众。这个遮阳结构受到如此大的空间限制的另一个原因是因为洛杉矶控制公共通行权的众多机构之间存在着一种倾向，不好意思，就是不能很好地协同工作。如果你跟街道部门或其他公共工程部门的人谈谈，他们都有充分的理由在各自的机构内部工作。他们没有得到适当的指示去合作和协调那些全面服务于选民的项目，
which are the public who, to be honest, don't really care who's jurisdiction sidewalk is. They just want an accessible place where they're not going to pass out waiting for the bus. So if you're only working, let's say, with the transportation agency, which has a very limited real estate that they had permitted in the sidewalk, you're only going to be able to work on that bus pole. If you want to work with the streets department, you have to get permitting, you have to go through another process. And then if you work with them,
这些选民老实说并不在乎是谁管辖的人行道。他们只是想要一个无障碍的地方，在那里他们不会因为等公交车而晕倒。所以如果你只是与交通机构合作，而交通机构在人行道上获准的房地产非常有限，你就只能在那根公交杆上工作。如果你想和街道部门合作，你必须获得许可，你必须经历另一个流程。然后如果你和他们合作，
you find that there are all these other obstructions that don't have to do with ADA, but have to do with say, the vision triangle and clearance, if there's a driveway, you can't be six to 10 feet with them that driveway, so drivers can see what's happening, so they don't run over pedestrian.
你会发现还有所有这些其他的阻碍，这些阻碍与ADA无关，而是与比如视线三角区和净空有关，如果有一个车道，你不能在那个车道6到10英尺范围内，这样司机才能看到发生了什么，才不会撞倒行人。
There's guy wire, holding up a overhead power line, you can't be building a bus shelter or planting a tree near there. All these other infrastructures that we know are important for cities. They all come well before anyone ever gets to say, I want to put a tree there. I want to put a bus shelter there. So it comes last or in some cases, not at all. I think part of the problem was that this was announced with this triumphant tone of achievement. When, as other people have since suggested to me, what if the press conference could have instead been,
有拉线支撑着架空电线，你不能在那里建公交候车亭或种树。所有这些我们知道对城市很重要的其他基础设施。在任何人有机会说“我想在那里种棵树。我想在那里建个公交候车亭”之前，它们就已经排在前面了。所以它排在最后，或者在某些情况下，根本没有。我认为部分问题在于，这是带着一种胜利的成就感宣布的，然而，正如其他人后来向我建议的那样，如果新闻发布会可以变成这样呢：
look at what we're allowed to do because of the way we govern public space in Los Angeles. Look at this minor incursion that we are only allowed to do here. What if we could do something bigger? I mean, to me, it's pretty interesting because I think Las Ubrida is exactly the size of our desire to fix the problem. If you're criticizing its size, you should be criticizing the fact that this is all you get.
看看因为我们在洛杉矶管理公共空间的方式，我们被允许做什么。看看这个我们只被允许在这里进行的微小侵入。如果我们能做点更大的事情呢？我的意思是，对我来说，这非常有趣，因为我认为“小阴凉”的大小正好是我们解决问题欲望的大小。如果你在批评它的尺寸，你应该批评这样一个事实：这就是你所能得到的全部。
And that should be the story. Well said. Sam, this has been great. It's been great reconnecting with you. that this is all you get and that should be the story. Well said. Sam, this has been great. It's been great reconnecting with you. It's nice to see you again. Thanks so much. Yeah, thanks for having me.
事情本来就该如此。说得好。萨姆，这次聊得太棒了。很高兴能与你重新联系。这就是全部内容，事情本来就该如此。说得好。萨姆，这次聊得太棒了。很高兴能与你重新联系。很高兴再次见到你。非常感谢。是的，谢谢邀请我。
Really appreciate it. 99% of what was produced this week by Chris Barube. Sam Block is working on a book about Sh, and he's looking for stories about how shade is changing people's lives. If you have a great shade story, visit our website at 999pi.org, and we'll have instructions for sharing your story with Sam. Sound mix for today's episode by Martin Gonzalez,
非常感谢。本周99%的内容由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作。萨姆·布洛克正在写一本关于树荫的书，他正在寻找关于树荫如何改变人们生活的故事。如果你有一个精彩的树荫故事，请访问我们的网站 999pi.org，上面会有与萨姆分享你故事的说明。今天的节目混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯负责，
Music by Swan Rao. Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kurt Colstead is our digital director. Our intern is Anna Castanero. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Jason Dillion, Boshamadon, Jacob Moltenado Medina, Kelly Prone, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. 99% of visible is part of this Titcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered
音乐由斯旺·饶创作。德兰妮·霍尔是我们的资深编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监。我们的实习生是安娜·卡斯塔内罗。团队的其他成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莉、杰森·迪利安、博沙马adon、雅各布·莫尔特纳多·梅迪纳、凯利·普罗恩、乔·罗森伯格以及我罗曼·马尔斯。99%的视觉标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创建。99%的视觉是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在
six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find links to other Titcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
向北六个街区，位于潘多拉大楼。美丽而繁华的奥克兰上城，加利福尼亚州。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜爱的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。目前本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。